تسليم مسعود ابو عجيله للولايات المتحده
من المتحده من اجل المحاكمه في قضيه لوبي
لا يزال ليشغل بال القاسي والثاني هناك في
ليبيا ويثير لغه كبيرا العديد من الاطراف
استنكرت تسليما ابو عجيله لواشنطن وطلبت
بفتح تحقيق وهو ما حدث فعلا حيث اعلن
النائب العام الليبي الصديق اكد البدء
بالتحقيق فيما وصفه حادث التسليم مسعود
ابو عجيله الى الولايات المتحده ايضا
النائب العام قال ان عمليه التسليم جرت
دون علم السلطات القضائيه الليبيه الى ذلك
ندد 44 حزبا سياسيا الليبيا بالواقعه
والدعوه الى الاعتصام امام مقررات الامم
المتحده وسفرات الولايات المتحده في
الداخليه والخارج وفي احد التسريبات التي
تخصم ملابسات القضيه قالت صحيفه نجار
ديانا البريطانيه ان اتفاقا جرائم رامه
قبل ثلاثه اشهر بين الاداره الامريكيه
ومسؤولين ليبيا من اجل تسليم ابو عجيله
مشيره الى ان المفاوضات بدات منذ عهد
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب